- Man.
God, do I want the world to melt.
- Yeah!
- You've got your perspective.
You want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(hip hop music)
How many of you are
collecting debt, for college?
Tell the truth, it's okay.
Just curious.
That, to me is, like, the
thing that I'm spending
my whole life trying to figure out.
Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Do you
think it's gonna, like,
die out, or change?
- Yeah.
College is new.
Guys, college is fucking new.
In 1940, which is five minutes ago,
not everybody's fucking
dream was to go to college.
- [Audience Member] What do
you think is going to happen?
- I don't know, but I know
it's in trouble, you know?
Like this conversation was
not happening 10 years.
When the economy collapses,
on the back of all
the college debt, that
all of you are occurring,
and everybody blames the
racket of college for it.
It will be, like banks, or
other things, the brand will be
so bad, the conversation will change,
and I do believe that you will
be the generation of parents
that don't force your
kids to go to college.
So, I think 30.
I think Stanford, Harvard,
I think the top 17
will be able to hold on a little
bit longer, just on brand.
But I think the really good
schools, like the state schools,
kind of that upper middle, I
think they're very vulnerable.
Michigan's an amazingly good school,
but collecting 200,000 in
debt, with that interest rate,
for a good solid Michigan degree,
in the real life, the day after?
No way.
Yeah?
I'm gonna get all that.
So this machine, that is
stupid now, gets really smart
because we'll go from 280, to
590 in revenue, in 24 months.
It'll be profitable revenue,
because the world will melt,
and I'll be able to higher all the people,
from other agencies, for
25 cents on the dollar.
At the same time, a bunch of companies
are going to be over leveraged,
and are gonna go out of
business, and I'm gonna be able
to buy those businesses with
the cash flow of the 590,
at higher revenue.
Then the economy's gonna
turn back in 12 years,
and I'll be able to sell those
businesses at the frothy end,
and buy the jets.
(laughs)
- [Audience Member] What's
happening after the jets?
- Super Bowls.
(laughs)
You see what I'm doing?
I'm playing the reverse game.
So, everybody thinks it's stupid now,
because they don't
understand it's over valued.
Then it's gonna seem very smart.
And, then I'm gonna be
able to show this video
and be like, it wasn't an accident.
Which will only compound
the smartness of it.
And I'll be 62, and have 40
years to play, all on the equity
of pulling off a billion dollar
thing, on smarts, not luck.
On humility of eating shit
for a decade, in my prime.
Kids are gonna watch
these videos and be like,
he was fucking 39, he was 42.
Like, I'm 26.
And he was patient, that's why it worked.
I'm gonna do that.
Nobody's ever seen anybody play it.
When do you get to watch
Steve Jobs' first nine years.
And, not that I'm mad, or
this and that, it's just like,
we didn't get to see Bezos packing books.
Do you know how powerful
it would be, right now?
How many views do you think?
- [Audience Member] 89.
- No, how many views do
you think, if Jeff Bezos
was doing a blog, those first 50 episodes,
of him packing books in a
fucking garage, would have?
80 million?
Maybe 14 billion?
Right?
Everybody would watch it.
I mean everybody.
Yeah.
So, How'd you like to
watch Michael Jordan's
first three off seasons,
and the work he put in.
So, there's a lot of thought
that goes into what I do,
that I don't speak about,
or I show glimpses of
in things like this.
My team talks a lot about me
not talking about being smart.
As you guys know, none of my content
is predicated on being smart.
That's just gonna speak for itself,
when it's all said and done.
I don't need people to think I'm smart.
(mellow music)
So, if you want a BMW,
on money you don't have,
because you want to look
good amongst your peer set,
that you've made it, and
you haven't, you will lose.
You will lose.
Especially during this era, right now,
where the market is good.
If you're not winning right
now, you really fucking suck.
(laughs)
It's the truth.
Because this is not fucking
2001, this is not 2008.
You know, even less people
buy water filtration systems
when the fucking market collapses?
Less people.
You know how many less people buy,
fucking cases of $4000 wine, like today,
was happening at Wine Library,
when the market collapses?
Less people.
You know how many less people
are buying, fucking homes?
A lot less people.
Real life.
And, like, what's so fun
for me is, this is 100%.
I will not live the rest of my life
in a bullish market, in growth.
So recalling, like, I can't
wait to air this content,
the day the whole fucking world melts.
And, it's gonna be like, I told you so,
and I hope you did something about it.
Because now it gets really weird.
- [Audience Member] I
heard you made that comment
about student loan debt.
- I'm gonna be so right
about that, I'm gonna be so,
historically right about that.
They're lending money
to kids in huge debt.
There's nothing else to say,
there's nothing else to say.
The banks are doing it again.
This time it's not bullshit, and mortgage,
things you guys understand
better, I still don't fully.
I mean, I understand
packaging up horseshit,
and not having a true system.
You guys, probably in a
younger sense, you guys know.
You have friends, or acquaintances,
who are 180,000 in debt,
on 9% interest, are making $47,000 a year,
and are buying expensive
shit, or have a new apartment.
(mellow music)
We're counting everybody
else's points too much.
Worry about your own shit.
Now, that bubble will burst,
and then we'll get to see
who's still around, and then
we'll see everybody else
who says entrepreneur, in their
Instagram profile right now,
when they're working Bank
of America in 24 months.
And so, that's what I'm waiting for.
I'm most excited for, and
waiting for, and hoping for,
complete, global economic carnage,
so that we can weed out the
B, and C, and D players.
- [Man] Well Jesus, if you had
stopped talking a minute ago,
we would've ended on a high note,
but instead we ended on that.
- By the way, that's where
I think this is so fun,
I think that is a high note.
It's the same way I'm looking
at what's happening now.
The truth should win.
If you're a piece of
shit, you should lose.
If you're not a good entrepreneur,
you should have a job.
Merit, and the truth, are always
the winners, in the macro.
We're just in a micro, right
now, and people are confused.
(mellow music)
God, do I want the world to melt.
You know why?
People are confused, everybody thinks
I want the world to melt,
because I do a bad job
at communicating, because I
like keeping a lot of shit in,
that I'm gonna take advantage of it.
I want the world to melt, because people
are gonna be happier.
- That's really interesting.
- Tom, people are in fake environments.
No listen, this is why Tom's smart, man.
He gets it, he gets it right away.
I'm serious, people are gonna be happier.
Because everybody's living
a fake life right now,
and keeping up with the Joneses,
and when everything melts,
everybody gets back to the right.
Not paying the piper, in 2009, in America,
for the economic melting,
and going through seven years
of a recession, and us
propping up, fucked our culture
in a way that nobody talks about.
- Have you read the
stand, by Stephen King?
- I don't read shit.
- Of course, I already knew the answer.
- [Gary] Well can you
break it down for me?
- Here we go, yeah.
Because it literally
speaks to exactly this.
The center character
of the book is somebody
who's just popping off, as a musician,
right when this world ending flu happens.
But the guy survives.
And so he goes from, everybody loves me,
they're treating me well,
I've got free cocaine,
and then now, no one
knows who the fuck I am.
And that whole machinery,
that was about to make me
the biggest thing on the planet,
just fell out from under him.
- [Gary] And he's solo?
- Well, he's not solo,
because there's enough people
to survive, but he
realizes all that bullshit
that he was chasing, now
it just doesn't exist.
So, there's this
simplification of life, and,
to your point, as he gets
beyond that hunger for the fame,
and the adulation, and just
has to deal with staying alive,
his life actually gets better.
- I love this shit.
God, can I now wait for
the economic meltdown,
because it's the beginning of
happiness, at a bigger scale.
(hip hop music)